Oh God okay morning John the guns
happening I don't know I'm gonna make my
video this week I didn't prepare
properly so let's go do this I just have
time to go start rehearsing with the
perfect strangers there's definitely I
don't have my hotel key this is hard
this is the battery from my phone which
is like four or five times bigger than
my phone because it needs to be charged
like three time not wearing shoes I
don't know what elevators are supposed
to do this is the first person who asked
me for a picture okay oh I don't know if
I pass yet so I can't go in there and
I'm not even on the floor I want to be
on yet what's that gonna be so haven't
got on the escalator I realized I didn't
have my bad
so I wasn't allowed to go to any of the
places that I need to get on the shirts
what were they doing up there
oh that's Dave our warehouse manager and
also merge manager at VidCon also writer
for scishow and also really friend of
Michael gardener hey cuz how you feeling
great this is Julie sometimes I tweet
about Julie this is who Julie is she
makes my life work Expo all getting set
up the escalators are off this dis is
Rob waiting for me outside the wing
[Music]
reversal had to take a break for a
beanbag Mountain
[Music]
marry me and feedbags I don't want to
about the world anymore it's too hard
I'm like four beanbags down now leaving
rehearsal Craig needs me
Craig wheezy waiter I don't know why he
needs before what for but he does so I'm
gonna go find him around age I run out
of the Convention Center and then I'm in
the desert running through the desert
whichever gap would it go I found John
no just by the way my badge has higher
clearance than John's me that represents
progress okay this is kind of a moment
of truth for me I haven't seen the stage
or the arena yet Oh wha okay very cool
very thirsty but it's difficult for me
to drink these drinks because I know how
much they cost I'm doing it anyway our
pillows are parently semi-sentient this
is what it looks like backstage at
VidCon this is what my dad looks like oh
thanks wires
it's a Tyler hi Tyler
hi this is the part where we talk about
how we're going to do what we're going
to do figure out what kind of mics we
need Monica tell us what to do basically
rehearsed
and now John is off to do an air biscuit
need a moral of the story what's the
moral of the story the moral of the
story is that your ability to come up
with new ideas and execute them
continues to astonish me ah but not in a
good way really more in an overwhelmed
way so don't say oh just checking out
what's going on in the expo hall now
gotta say hug everything we really it's
in one elevator let's go grab the drum
that fell off the cart thank you I'm
back in my hotel room because I have to
grab my computer so that I can go to a
technical rehearsal which is where you
plug your computer into a thing and you
see if your PowerPoint presentation is
going to work I think if it gun is
mostly walking for me this is a big room
just where I'm giving my industry
presentation I'm not a welcome party
welcoming people who came to
of us out a good guy yeah sorry yeah
being excited hey everybody its Natalie
trying first thing when you meet a new
youtuber is you're like you're not
average height so I was like you're
super short you know
hey gatherings here you made big Natalie
Tran gave me Tim Tams best thing that
was the day before VidCon started John
I'll see you in the morning